alerte là pour terminer la réouverture
de la galerie des as après trois ans de
travaux on en a déjà parlé ici même
l'emblème du château de versailles a
retrouvé tout son éclat c'était
aujourd'hui la journée d'inauguration
avant d'accueillir le public cette
semaine
emmanuel lambert annie triboit et non
vous ne rêvez pas nous sommes de retour
au temps de louis xiv bon d'accord le
roi soleil c'est un comédien et ce jour
là nous étions sur le tournage d'un
téléfilm mais la galerie des glaces elle
est aussi belle qu'en 16 184 du sol au
plafond
le joyau de versailles a été entièrement
rénové 73 mètres de long 12 mètres de
haut le monarque voulait impressionner
pour retrouver cette splendeur disparu
il a fallu trois ans de travaux et 12
millions d'euros une opération financée
par une grande entreprise française
certes nous on a mis presque autant de
temps pour le restaurer que lebron pour
le réaliser et donc c'est pas forcément
un exploit sur les délais par contre je
pense que le résultat est quand même
très encourageant pendant 48 mois 100
techniciens se sont penchés au chevet de
la galerie diagnostic elle était un peu
pâle bien loin de son faste originel
alors peinture dorures parquet tout a
été refait 70% des miroirs navy pas
bougé depuis 323 ans
les restaurateurs ont respecté les
matériaux de l'époque
ça aurait été la faute de goût ultime de
remettre du miroir 9
c'est des fautes qu'on fait les
restaurateurs à une époque
ce 9e rhum qui n'avait pas du tout la
même culture
aujourd'hui et c'est quelque chose
auquel je n'aurais pas voulu participer
ce matin plus de 200 journalistes du
monde entier étaient en admiration
on pourrait avoir le fantasme vers
l'histoire française
c'est pour ça de tous les coréens sont
ils ont très envie de voir le galère et
des glaces acturevue fois jeff
aujourd'hui quand un japonais visitent
paris le détour par versailles est
obligatoire symbole du savoir faire
français symbole de puissance la galerie
des glaces pourrait être admirés dès
demain chaque année quatre millions de
touristes viennent flâner dans
l'ancienne demeure des rois